what the hell is going on in Dominican
Republic and all these tourists dying
and I'm trying to fly my whole family
out this time to go as far as price is
concerned I for the 11 tourists just
died I think 50 people got sick at a
Jimmy Buffett concert and as of today
wait was that from Jimmy Buffett and D
are unconfirmed so many margaritas but
dr is coming out and saying like there's
nothing going on there's a new guy that
went down after all this has happened
and then got sick or is this like one
that just they hadn't accounted for they
said he had a heart attack
oh I'm dying I'm saying they all had a
heart attacks don't worry about it come
on down join us you can never guess what
happens yeah like so the guy died from a
heart attack yeah and it's like oh
nobody knows what happened nobody knows
what happened let me tell you having as
a card-carrying Dominican I summer there
every year as a kid as a teenager as a
young adult now like I got four kids so
it's like a little more difficult
listicle II [ __ ] go out there
to buy [ __ ] let's be real my alleged
allegedly yeah it's like that dude
definitely bought like some aftermarket
viagra allegedly viagra I was poor
caught like bigger powers there's ill we
did Brazil three times you buy that
right over the counter the viagra and a
lot I don't know who is the actual
viagra or you're really taking a chance
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app